- Le tourisme régional a-t-il
pris son envol au Québec, depuis
que le gouvernement à fait
plafonner à 500 $ le prix
des billets d'avio
FRANÇOIS BONNARDEL, ministre
des Transports du Québec
- C'est un pas important
pour l'industrie touristique.
C'est unne régionale.
- Difficile à dire pour
l'instant, faute de données.
Mais déjà, des acteurs
du milieu parlentet limité.
PAUL LAVOIE, directeur général,
Tourisme Côte-Nord
- L'impact n'a pas été notable.
Pas au par exemple, nous ont
mentionné, là, qu'il y avait
vraiment eu un impact.
- Du 1er juin au 15 août,
c'est 94qui ont été vendus danse
du programme d'accès aérien
aux régions, programme qui rend,
PAL Airlines, qui offre plus
d'une vingtaine de connexions
au Québec et dans l'Est du pays,
dit avoir vendu plus de bill
comme Sept-Îles.
TOMMY DESFOSSÉS, directeur
des affaires chez PAL Airlines
- On a vu une augmentation
Cette année, on semble avoir
vu des gens issus de tous
les milieux qui y vont
- La reprise des voyages
les billets d'avion en régions
éloignéees pourraient
expliquer cette tendance,
explique l'Union des
DANIEL CÔTÉ, maire de Gaspé,
ion des municipalités
- Honnêtement, c'était difficile
de se trouver un vol à cer
tellement les volsétaient étaie.
- Mais pour le professeur Mehran
Ebrahimi, l'investissementdollas
sur deux ans de la CoalitionAves
la chandelle.
MEHRAN EBRAHIMI, derv. aéronervM
- Sincèrement, je pense que
c'est un gaspillage de l'argent
public. Subventionner des sièges
n'a jamales régions, ni pour
les compagnies aériennes.
- Alors que le gouvernement
entend stimuler la demande
intervenants demandent
à ce qu'il y ait plus d'hôtels,
plus de transport et plus
de flexibilité sur les heures
accompagner les visiteursdès lee
coins du Québec.